you know what you're supposed to do eat
them and I think everybody does a lot of
people just don't go after it I think
everybody has talent and all you have to
do is find what your talents are and put
focus into it I want to get famous by
the time I'm 21 I'm 19 back in myself
two years he's an American comedian
actor writer singer and producer he was
ranked number 10 on Comedy Central's 100
greatest stand-up comedians of all time
in 2015 his films made him the sixth
highest-grossing actor in the United
States he's Eddie Murphy and here is my
take on his top ten rule to success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end become special bonus clips also
as Eddie's talking if he says something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
a very spiritual person and I follow my
spirit and I do what my spirit tells me
to do you know and I don't have a said
like oh I want to play this type of
character and I won't play that that's
character I'm receptive to anything you
know and when the right thing comes
along at the serious if it's funny is it
silly if it's low bus yeah but it put
this what I do I just do whatever makes
me I get the most gratification from as
an audition I do music albums and nobody
buys my records I do it because I love
making music here and that's the same
way I'm about movies I don't make movies
because I'm going to think and let me do
this because when people are come or how
much will the movie making I'm trying to
make the audience do that I do with a
feel the rightful I know I want to be in
show business and I just happened to
luck out and things happen I think you
know you know you if you know what
you're supposed to do deep down inside I
think everybody does a lot of people
just don't go after it you know and like
most people start out they say I want to
be exist but I'm going to get that to
make sure I have something to fall back
on and what you're doing is you set
yourself up a fake because you're going
and there's a possibility that I'm gonna
fall back and when you put that out
there then you fall back they just say
hey this is what I want to do and you go
do it you usually get your stuff to
where you want it
I don't think I'll ever give anybody
there's any interaction it was all the
advice I can give it was wrong
I don't agree that we shouldn't college
life because the metric that's always
like everybody could take out my
spongebob advice but everybody's life is
different everybody's got different
something works for John I mean it's
going to work for me do your own thing
and you kids out there do what you want
if your parents want you to do something
else do what you want because none at
the same time she'll be right and if you
become a bum hey we told you not to take
advice right my whole family is funny I
have a really funny funny
samih like weird the whole family can
tell jokes and do the dozens and on so
we're always really funny around the
house and when I realized what I want to
be a comedian was Richard Pryor who was
like oh les that's what I wanted 1976 I
think it was a the album he put out
called that [ __ ] crazy and I remember
just sitting and listening to it over
and over and over and over and over and
over and that was kind of where it
started that's what I realized when I
was what I want to do yeah I just want
to be known as a person who who wanted
to make people feel good it was Eddie
cheese for comedy that caught the eye of
Hollywood and turn Eddie Murphy the
comedian into Eddie Murphy the movie
star
have me Luca I'm sorry about the doorman
did that hurt it looks real painful when
you slammed into it I think everybody
has talent and all you have to do is
find what your talents are and put focus
into it and when I was 15 I knew I was
going to be in show business and I knew
that's what I was going to do I'm just
the comedian you know now to really
listen critic that's some cool person
could I guess because I could criticize
or live you can't listen to it I just do
what I do you know I can't I don't when
they take good things I don't sit around
for a year that's right when is it best
and you read everything I read
everything there you have a clipping
service that you eat everything I've
read pretty much everything and I just
say you can pretty much tell what's in
my head with the you know but I've never
taken any advice from an article that
were it because I got like I feel like
I'm an artist
and if you read an artist the best
picture I think is like the first thing
they did then creates come around and
say if he had done the eyes different
and then the next time you paint you
going they didn't like the eyes so I
should and I'm not I just do nothing
I've been the class clown and I was a
little kid I started out of the class
clown from class clown I went to the
school clown from the school clown I
went through the neighborhood clown and
like now everybody knows me and the guy
what I found
funnier
I want to you know I would like thanks
for choosing another career I think I'd
go pray there's nothing else I could do
I decided to very am 19 now I decided
when I was 17 and I want to go into this
for real and I was familiar with
stand-up comedy and entertainment 2015 a
lot of kids tell their parents they want
to be doctors and lawyers and garbage
like that but I want to be a stand-up
comedian I told my parents that and
everything is working out for me fine
I'm growing constantly on stage and
everything is working out for I like
very much the invitations you did the
impressions were great I want to get
famous by the time I'm 21 I'm 19 now I
give myself two years how do a little
exercise you know just to keep it fit
you know but more than anything is ever
know that the least amount of that's the
stress is really the thing that really
eats you up and have such a small stress
level for years and years and when I
have something that's stressful that I
have to deal what I've really learned
how to deal with it and put it in the
back mat sit around very rarely should
you sit around a house like this
you're on pollution emissions here of
course you got any the thing is I could
tell you what's the most gratifying
thing the most gratifying things me as a
nagas is to be able to have some
longevity and being able to connect to
what the audience you know different
generations would be around for a while
especially you know in a business where
you know people come and go so fast in
the movie business just to be able to
connect with an audience you know when
you were 19 and you can still connect
with them people still appreciate what
you what you do that's the most
gratifying and fleshy part that's the
most gratifying how do you think artists
should move forward if they're feeling
discouraged or feeling I guess stressed
out about kind of everything that's
going on in the world well it kind of is
what it is now so just Cantina
there's nothing you could do it it is
what it is so you know go to get it
right keep it rolling
I I think this is a great country and I
think it's the greatest country in the
world and I think that uh all this to
get worked out I'm optimistic person I'm
not you know
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because spikes to 108
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what Clips
resonated the most with you today which
of the clips from Eddie had the biggest
impact on you that you're going to
immediately apply to your life or your
business somehow leave it in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Noah Sachs Noah thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and tweeting that
picture out I'm looking forward to the
review thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
um one reasons why I was so successful
on the shoulder because I didn't take
the show as seriously as other people in
the cat yeah a lot of people that like
this was their shot and I like 19 years
old when I was doing that stuff and uh
it was just fun to me I think an
audience picked up even if you if what
you're doing is really that funny if you
haven't a ball yeah the audience kind of
picks up with it and I think that's why
but you could take material that
ordinarily wouldn't be funny if somebody
else did it and make it funny I think
that was a compliment without copy that
was a compliment because you're like
what you're doing funny but it's fun now
we can happen